they'll go up against the rangers
starter today that is kyle gibson who's
5-0 with a 2-1-7 era that's third behind
a couple of white sox in lancelin and
carlos rodon
down on the count 0-2
and good off speed pitch for the
strikeout one and two as gibson comes
home
and gets another strikeout that time on
the fastball
back-to-back case to close a perfect top
of the first for kyle gibson rangers
coming up this will be an opener for
kansas city and they've done this a
couple of times in fact they did this
against boston last week with kyle
zimmer starting off the game he'll get
the start today
this 3-0 is low and it's a four-pitch
walk to low
zimmer zoe two is cut on and missed at
96 as he ramped it up to get the
strikeout two down
2-2
went around that one gets away from
perez the runners take off but perez
definitely takes care of it at first
base a couple of strikeouts for zimmer
and he leaves a couple of stranded
scoreless to the second
one and two on o'hearn and he waves
through
gibson mixing up the speeds well he has
spanned three straight
tried to check he could not
goes around that is four straight
strikeouts
for kyle gibson two down
gibson home with a 2-2
got him six up six down five strikeouts
consecutively 22 pitches from kyle
zimmer as the opener today
and he'll give way to chris bubich
oh that one came up and in and got a
piece of calhoun now an appeal down to
third base no swing says ben may so
it'll be a hit by pitch
shows bunt and puts it down he's been a
great punter this year and he gets
another one a couple of hits yesterday
to bust out of a funk and now lays one
down to advance calhoun into scoring
position trevino comes up hitting 231
let's see if holt's running on three and
two
he is and the pitch is lined to left
center field that one headed for the
alley and that is in there four extra
bases
all the way to the wall one run is home
here comes brock holt and he will score
a ringing two run double for jose
trevino
gives the rangers a two to nothing lead
here's the dollies first and third two
outs
one-o pitch line drive centerfield base
hit
that scores trevino
it sends low down to second it makes it
three-nothing texas in the second 3-2
delivery runners go and he laid off of
it so already 62 pitches
by royals pitchers in the first inning
and two-thirds of this game
and a couple of walks by boobitch here
in the second irvin santana is going to
come in to eat some innings for kansas
city minor league contract with the
royals this year 2-2
and he freezes him
fastball and slider that's all you need
if you can throw a strike santana does
garcia with an rbi to make it three
nothing
here's the 3-2 again and that pitch on
the inside corner called third strike
front door slider that time from gibson
gets taylor
for the second out in the inning six
punch outs now for gibson and that
brings up nikki lopez
and the 2-2 pitch is hit back up the
middle right back into gibson's glove on
a couple of hops throw over to first and
lopez is retired one two three
go the royals as the gibson is perfect
through three we'll go to the bottom of
the third inning with texas leading
three nothing and he has thrown a first
pitch strike to eight of the ten hitters
that he has faced thus far
merrifield hammers one to left white
ranging back to the track and he's got
it
hard hit but
eaten up by globe life field and it's
one away
[Applause]
perez ropes it to short what a play
isaiah kinder philippa showing off the
gold glove
did it at third last year doing it in
short this season one of the top
defensive shortstops in the league
royall's play is he to pull
but not an overshift in the infield
santana well off the line at first
though as this ball is flared into right
center on the move is solaire but he
won't get there it falls for the base
hit so a soft flare
drops out into right center and tanner
valencia is now one for three
there he goes
and ball four garcia is support for the
second time two on and two out for joey
gallo
he's knocked in 295 and maybe more a
high fly deep right center field taylor
turning to look it's gone
over the ranger bullpen
home run number 14 of the year for joey
gallo it's a three run shot and the
rangers lead six nothing
gibson ready and brings the next
offering and it's pounded back up the
middle and that's a base hit first base
runner for the royals today
and he
ends the perfect game at four innings
the 3-2 pitch
hit in the ground to the left side
fielded by the third baseman only play
will be first and gutierrez is safe we
beat the throw so the royals have two on
with nobody out here in the top of the
fifth inning
[Applause]
3-2
and that's a
really good at bat from solaire i'm not
even sure if he was fully fully sold it
was a walk
really trying to get these guys to chase
like that he does that time first out of
the inning is a big one that is
the seventh strikeout today for gibson
as well
he's home with an one
chopper to third grab by holt step on
the bag fire across double play
gibson's pumped up
a twin killing to close the threat in
the top of the fifth inning
rock hold towards the gap right center
field and deep back towards the wall and
it's off the top of the fence
holt will stop at second with a two out
double that was a long loud two bagger
for brock holt just missed what would
have been his second home run of the
year
rox flexing on him and he needed about
two more curls to get this part
to punch that on the ground to the right
side santana to santana to get trevino
and end the frame
playing an awesome defense
[Applause]
hard head oh what a play
brock holt
robs lopez of a base hit
got him
went around by three pitches to get
merrifield mirrorfield was off balance
that entire at-bat pitch one
this one is swung on and bounded into
the shift it is brock holtz
on the right side of the infield with a
short toss to first good defense in that
frame and a one two three inning work by
gibson other than the fifth he's been
sparking here's the set the pitch and
that is line to right a basic for garcia
another opposite field hit for adoles
the second single of the ball game it
moves low on down to second stomach
comes home
and the fastball again a swinging strike
again and he strikes out the side with a
couple of base runners stranded to the
seventh and later in xuego
and a swing and a miss on a fastball
from gibson perez strikes out
so that's a new season high for kyle
gibson nine strikeouts outfield fans
toward left
as gibson fires the o2 pitch and he's in
there with a call third strike fastball
more toward the top of the zone so make
that 10 strikeouts and now gibson is one
away from his career best
bouncing ball to conner falefa long
throw
in time to get gutierrez
with another base nine
that is hits in four of his last five
games since being called back up to the
big club
hard hit towards the gap in left center
field taylor was trying to play and then
opted to hold back on it instead of
diving for it
and he'll hold
ivanya's at second base
solac with a single back-to-back knocks
off of davis to start the seventh for
texas
two-two to connor falefa bouncing ball
to gutierrez he'll fire across
would have reached that time by hunter
and that'll do it one out rangers
leading six nothing for joey gallow
there's a high drive well hit the center
field taylor going back on the track at
the wall and that ball's history
the top of the hitter's backdrop the
landing spot for joey gallows second
home run of the game
his 15th of the year
and the rangers lead at eight tonight
and the pitch
hit high in the air to short left center
field
white and garcia are there garcia makes
the catch the ball game's over the
rangers have won it eight to nothing